speaking of asserts uh exceptions are
called errors why is it called errors so
we I mean we we use the same we're the
same as python right but um we
implemented a very different way right
and so if you look at um other languages
like we'll pick on C plus plus our
favorite right uh C plus plus has this
thing called zero cost exception
handling
okay see and this is
in my opinion
something to learn lessons from it's a
nice playwear thing and so
um and so zero cost exception handling
the way it works is that it's called
zero cost because
if you don't throw an exception there's
supposed to be no overhead for the
non-error code and so it takes the air
path out of the uh the common path
um it does this by making throwing an
error extremely expensive and so if you
actually throw an error with a c plus
compiler using exceptions let's go look
up in tables on the side and do all this
stuff and so throwing an error could be
like 10 000 times more expensive than
referring from a function right also
it's called zero cost exceptions but
it's not zero cost by any stretch of the
imagination because it massively blows
out your code your binary it also adds a
whole bunch of different paths because
of destructors and other things like
that that exist in C plus plus and it
reduces the number of optimizations it
has like all these effects and so this
thing that was called zero cost
exceptions it really ain't okay now if
you fast forward to newer languages and
um and this includes Swift and rust and
go and and now Mojo
um
uh well in Python's a little bit
different because it's interpreted and
so like it's got a little bit of a
different thing going on but if you look
at it if you look at compiled languages
um many newer languages say okay well
let's not do that zero cost exception
handling thing let's actually treat in
throwing an error the same as returning
a variant returning either the normal
result or an error now
programmers generally don't want to deal
with all the typing machinery and like
pushing around a variant and so you use
all the syntax that python gives us for
example try and catch and it you know
functions that raise and things like
this you can put a raises decorator on
your functions stuff like this and if
you want to control that and then the
language can provide Syntax for it but
under the hood the way the computer
executes it throwing error is basically
as fast as returning something
interesting so it's exactly the same way
it is from a compiled perspective and so
this is actually I mean it's a fairly
nerdy thing right which is why I love it
um but the uh this has a huge impact on
the way you design your apis
right so in C plus plus
huge communities turn off exceptions
because the cost is just so high right
and so the zero cost cost is so high
right and so that means you can't
actually use exceptions in many
libraries
right and even for the people that do
use it well okay how and when do you
want to pay the cost if I try to open a
file should I throw an error well what
if I'm probing around looking for
something right I'm looking it up in
many different paths well if it's really
slow to do that maybe I'll add another
function that doesn't throw an error it
returns an error code instead and now I
have two different versions the same
thing and so it causes you to Fork your
apis
and so you know one of the things I
learned from Apple and I still love is
the art of API design is actually really
profound I think this is something that
Python's also done a pretty good job at
in terms of building out this
large-scale package ecosystem it's about
having standards and things like this
and so you know we wouldn't want to
enter a mode where
um you know there's this theoretical
feature that exists in language but
people don't use it in practice
now I also say one of the other really
cool things about this implementation
approach is that it can run on gpus and
it can run accelerators and things like
this and that standard zero cost
exception thing would never work on an
accelerator and so this is also part of
how Mojo can scale all the way down to
like little embedded systems and to
running on gpus and things like that can
you actually say about the
maybe uh is there some high-level way to
describe the challenge of exceptions and
how they work in code during compilation
so just this idea of percolating up a
thing
an error yeah yeah so the way the way to
think about it is
um think about a function that doesn't
return anything just as a simple case
right and so you have
function one calls function two calls
function three calls function four
along that call stack that are try
blocks right and so if you have function
one calls function two function two has
a try block and then within it it calls
function three right well what happens
if function three throws
well actually start simpler what happens
if it returns well if it returns it's
supposed to go back out and continue
executing and then fall off the bottom
of the try block and keep going and all
is good
if the function throws you're supposed
to exit the current function
and then get into the accept Clause
right and then do whatever code's there
and then keep falling on and going on
and so the way that a compiler like Mojo
works is that the call to that function
which happens in the accept block calls
the function and then instead of
returning nothing
it actually returns you know a variant
between nothing and an error
and so if you return normally fall off
the bottom or do a return
you refer nothing and if you throw throw
an error you
return the variant that is I'm an error
right so when you get to the call you
say okay cool I called a function hey I
know locally I'm in a try block
right and so I I call the function and
then I check to see what it returns aha
if it's that error thing jump to the
accept block
and that's all done for you behind the
scenes exactly and so the competitors
all this for you and I mean one of the
things if you dig into how this stuff
works in Python it gets a little bit
more complicated because you have
finally blocks which now need you need
to go into do some stuff and then those
can also throw and return wait what
that's good and like the stuff matters
for compatibility
um like there's there's with Clauses and
so with Clauses are kind of like finally
blocked with some special stuff going on
and so there's nothing in general
nothing of anything nothing of functions
should be illegal
it just feels like it adds a level of
complexity Alexa I'm merely an
implementer and so this is again yeah
one of one of the one of the trade-offs
you get when you decide to build a
superset is you get to implement a full
Fidelity implementation of the thing
that you decided is good and so
yeah I mean we can we can complain about
the reality of the world and Shake our
fist but it always feels like you
shouldn't be allowed to do that like to
declare functions and sudden functions
inside functions
what happened to lacks the the lisp guy
no I understand that but lisp is what I
used to do in college so now you've
grown up
you know we've all done things in
college we're not proud
okay yeah I was gonna say you're afraid
of me you're taking the whole internet
it's uh it worked it worked as a joke in
my head and yeah right so so nested
functions are joking aside actually
really great and for certain things
right and so these are also called
closures
closures are pretty cool and you can
pass callbacks there's a lot of good
patterns and so